anti-depressants weren't working we'd
been to every single therapist and
nothing was touching it until we used
Heim pronouns I don't even know where to
start here sex is not assigned at Birth
it's established at conception we have
to get to biology here today we're
bringing a new version of Middle Ground
we'll be exploring the topic should
miners be allowed to medically
transition we'll be introducing an
undecided group and they'll be listening
to a discussion between liberals and
conservatives and the undecided group
will pick a side after each
prompt
transitioning has become a social media
Trend absolutely agree I mean it is just
skyrocketing the amount of children that
you see falling into this and we need to
stop it absolutely not people said the
same thing about people coming out being
lesbian gay or bisexual as it got more
normalized as people became more
accepting of like their children and
things like that they're like everybody
wants to be gay now social media is
around people my age like we see other
transs people and being aware that
that's something that's being accepted
by other people makes you more
comfortable with with yourself and like
comfortable with like internalizing that
it's okay to be Trans in public I think
you're fing prey to the survivorship
bias which is just sort of you're
overlooking all the cases of people who
either weren't able to come out because
they weren't comfortable or safe to do
so or they either died due to Suicide or
other mental health reasons but over
time if you look at left-handedness that
Skyrocket in a similar rate as people
became more accepting to it I I I reject
that but let me ask you something if
that's the case if more people are
transitioning simply because it's more
acceptable then how can your side also
say that there's a trans genocide
happening those are completely opposite
no I know you didn't but you're but the
people but liberals say that all the
time they're saying that there's a trans
genocide because for some reason so I'm
just curious as to how you would square
that Circle can we Define what the trans
genocide I guess narrative is as raised
by her I would like her to answer that
cuz she's so never up yeah because so we
hear people saying because simply
because legislation is being passed
across the country that is Banning
minors from being able to transition
that automatically means that those
children would commit suicide and that
is simply an abusive statement of itself
statistically a lot of minors who aren't
able to transition who would like to do
end up why don't we have this why don't
we have this why don't we have the same
suicide rates in the past that we that
were that if if that was the case how
could we how could we have known that
the people who were committing suicide
were transgender if they didn't feel
safe to come out when you look at like
um members of each generation that
identifies as lgbtq or in that Community
it's like less than 2% and then for some
reason as soon as we get to Generation Z
it's 20% now some of you may argue okay
this is just because it's more open it's
more accepting now everyone it's okay to
be that but then in the same beat you
guys will say that if you don't accept
them they're more likely to commit
suicide or something but kind of sounds
like a double edged SW so that didn't
sound double-edged to me it sounded
pretty accurate like if you're not
accepting of somebody they're more
likely to be self-hating like if you're
telling somebody that they're not
allowed to do something they shouldn't
do something they're not fitting into
their own body especially experiencing
dysphoria in itself it's a mental battle
in general like so so to clarify your
point I think you're saying that
acceptance is what's leading to it is
that right it's a a mixture between
self-acceptance outer acceptance It's a
conversation between nature and nurture
like see here's the problem with that
there have been there's two longitudinal
studies alone that I could cite in
Sweden from 1973 to 2003 they looked at
a large number of subjects who had
before transition and after transition
and they had worse comorbidities they
had worse mental health issues Sweden is
a very tolerant liberal Progressive
country a study this year published in
Denmark
2023 42-year latitude longitudinal study
and what they found is that the mental
health issues did not decline they
actually were augmented it was worse for
individuals who thought that by
transitioning they would solve their
mental health issues it actually got
worse it doesn't help it doesn't solve
these issues it shows it's a contagion
that is the key word let's let's pause
there then what are your guys' thoughts
on let's saybe that's a pretty popular
figure that's been mentioned when it
comes to a social media influencer that
risen to fame because of that she's just
doing what she's doing I don't think
that she's doing anything wrong okay he
do you think that has or she her that's
transphobic do you think that has
inspired uh trans kids I think she's
also inspired allies to see the human
being behind the pronouns and the makeup
and the dress and to see that there's
someone who is going through a story and
that watching her go through that story
enabled us to see the humanity behind
her he is degrading women you see a
great disregard I mean look at the look
at the product that he was supposed to
be promoting it is fallen into her
pronouns are she
herob not that's not a phobia the truth
is not a phobia St here and let's uh go
over to the undecided
group
all right so undecided group you guys
are kind of like the common section
which side did you resonate with most
liberals or
conservatives so why did you resonate
most with the liberal group Trends pass
Trends
end so calling it a trend is saying that
these people's identities are just going
to go away and I don't think that's fair
why do you think that it's not
transphobic to
misgender because the concept of
misgendering is false there are two
Sexes there's male and female well it's
it's it's in the chromosomes it goes
beyond superficial or secondary
characteristics he is a male he was born
a male he will remain a male it doesn't
matter how many chemicals he puts into
his body or how many body parts are cut
off and I'll say this again telling the
truth is not a mental illness do you
have a response that yeah um I think
that there is a difference between sex
and gender then I know you're going to
disagree with me but transgender is its
own thing and he can she can
be see no don't try to blame that on me
you are using the wrong pronouns for
this woman and you're trying to no
influence something do you have a
specific question that you like to ask
the liberal group I would just like to
hear more from them because I feel like
it was very one-sided thank
you okay so you sat more on the
conservative side do you want to explain
why you decided to come here yeah um so
I think I mean there are I mean it is
just factual that there are more people
transitioning or at least coming out not
even just as transgender but just you
know within the lgbtq community as a
whole and so I do see you know I think
for me it does become a little bit
grayer when you start to say okay is
that because people are being like
influenced to transition or is it
because it's more accepting and people
are feeling more open and safe about
coming out and I think you know when
you're in you know a friend group or
when you you know associate with certain
people I think you are likelier to maybe
you know explore your gender a little
bit more or you know look more into
those Avenues and I think that can
influence someone to transition if you
know maybe beforehand that wouldn't have
been a consideration do you have a
specific question that you'd like to ask
either side yeah I guess I would like to
ask you know the liberal side you know
and I can't necessarily trace it back to
a specific time when this happened but I
do think we have seen recently you know
a rise in people identifying with
genders that aren't necessarily within a
binary would you say that's a rise you
know how would you I guess account for
that I think as I said earlier that is
just accounted by survivorship bias
people previously were not comfortable
enough with coming out and that's where
that difference comes from and
eventually that skyrocketing rate will
even out um I definitely do think that
that is kind of a factor of it that I
mean you know people are just coming out
more and are feeling more accepted I
absolutely do believe that you know that
is a good that social media has done but
I do also kind of push back on the idea
that it's just completely that like I
you know when you look at figures who
you know rise to prominence like for
example D um Dylan wany you know these
are people with huge platforms that you
know are reaching to you know younger
people who are at stages in their lives
where you know they are exploring ideas
of gender and gender expression and
identity and so I guess personally I
would push back a little bit against the
idea that it's just people who had it
been more accepting in the past they
would have come out I do think there is
you know a rise I mean I feel like the
numbers just don't really account for it
necessarily being just that group of
people I think there are people
especially youth who are identifying
more kind of on the gender Spectrum or
as transgender that maybe wouldn't have
for so you're the only undecided can you
clarify why you still remain undecided
um yeah I think the reason I remained
undecided was because although I
appreciate um the presentations of both
sides and I see both their points I was
still a little bit unclear um as far as
which what like each opinion was on each
side so um I would just be curious to
ask the liberal side do you guys is
there any like evidence that you guys
could present that would suggest um that
transitioning lowers the rate of suicide
I would say on one hand there there is
data that suggest that um trans miners
who are not able to medically transition
when they do want to their suicidality
um attempt rate is around 40% and that
drops to below 10% when they are able to
transition moreover if I would wasn't
able to transition and I didn't have any
support in my life I would probably kill
myself the conservatives uh you guys
were discussing social media contagion
could you present any other like Arena
as far as um other instances where we've
seen social media have that influence
on i' love to add just every aspect of
mainstream media so um CNN like all
mainstream news sources when we talk
about even like major corporations we
have pride month for God's sake right we
have an entire month where all
corporations all major corporations even
the government you know President Joe
Biden is putting a pride flag it seems
like every aspect of our like top dog
like main people in society are
promoting it right and then if you go
down to like social media um everyone's
promoting it right each Instagram or not
maybe not Twitter anymore or X now but
Tik Tok there's there's Trends there's
um things that are happening where it is
being promoted and the fact that there's
influencers I think is just proving the
fact that it is indeed a trend gender
dysphoria is a mental illness it is a
break with reality I'll start at where
I've said before there are two Sexes
it's determined not just by external
characteristics but by chromosomes when
somebody dies and is buried and 400
years later if they exume the body and
they test those bones they're going to
see that it's an XX or an XY it's a male
or a female it's a mental issue and you
want to treat it that way you treat it
with counseling with therapy reflecting
reality helping the person be to be
comfortable with the sex that they're
born with sex what do you guys think
about that calling it a mental illness
yes I want to respond to your comment
about bones and skeletons I study bio um
anthropology and actually they're moving
in a direction where they're using the
terminology like assumed or or estimated
gender because there is large um overlap
between the general sort of uh
estimations also no one's going to dig
up someone's bones unless they've
already consented to donating their
skeleton somewhere no one just goes gra
grave robbing for that but that's that's
that's irrelevant point is it's relevant
to bring it up then no no no it is
relevant to point out that sex is
determined at Birth and it doesn't
change but what's the point you're
making with the skeleton example the
point that it doesn't change even over
long periods of time i' like to hear a
little bit more from thank you for your
if you you're walking around life
constantly being told something like
what you're supposed to identify as and
you feel other than like of course as
time goes on you're going to feel worse
and worse about that specific thing I
don't think there's a reason to
transition if you don't have a mental
illness like there's something wrong in
your brain you should cut your hair
because you don't long hair W that is so
not a comparison so when when you when
you I mean when when I when it's it's
the opposite concept of gender or body
dysmorphia so when you look in the
mirror and you see what's wrong with
like you see you have an
uncomfortability with your secondary sex
characteristics and so the treatment is
to change that to m match with what you
what you want it to be but I mean he's
right you can't change your sex but it's
in the brain you treat the body to help
the brain it's not any different and and
honestly I'm somebody who I don't think
you should be we should stigmatized
mental illness that's the whole point is
you know I have anxiety PTSD from when I
was in the military and everything else
I don't think we should be stigmatizing
mental illnesses and so I think that
calling it for what it is is just
accepting that and it actually helps
with treatment and to what you're
treating because you're treating the
brain you have to go to a therapist you
have to go all of that so I think it's
no issue to call it I think and when you
treat the brain you don't cut the body
though I mean if somebody has bulimia or
anorexia you treat the reason why they
perceive themselves incorrectly if
somebody has dysmorphia you don't say we
just cut off a body part this is a
complete violation of the hypocracy is a
mental health condition and the
treatment for this condition is to do a
medical transition if that person
chooses to have those procedures done it
won't go away with just a simple pill
it's gender dysphoria has nothing to do
with sex and bones and and your DNA do
you think children are capable of making
that decision let me let me pose a
question homosexuality actually used to
be considered as a mental illness do you
think there's any correlation here with
what's going on currently with the Trans
movement it it has to do with the way
you present yourself and again I I call
it sex dysphoria because it's dysphoria
of your sex but it has to do with your
secondary sex characteristics that
you're presenting to society you know in
a lot of regards and even Deborah so
wrote this in end of gender she she
actually advocated for this because the
same hormone imbalance in the womb that
causes more you know femininity and
homosexuality seems to be very similarly
tied to gender dysphoria as well it's
just a it's it's a further step along
the way it's a further you know
condition and and I I agree where I use
I guess I use mental illness and mental
health condition synonymously
essentially so I think what's
interesting about this top topic is that
you know we need to consider both
statistics as well as personal anecdotes
if you guys don't mind do you want to
share a little bit about your personal
experiences with this particular topic
yeah so I actually I didn't even know
that trans people existed until I was
around like 19 I think I just that
information never came to me um I'm 25
right now I didn't really realize I was
trans until I was
22 and I started medically transitioning
when I was 23 i' I've experienced
depression for most of my life probably
since I was like 13 or or so and um a
lot of suicidal ideation throughout high
school and early in college but pretty
much around the time I had I guess felt
comfortable with my like where i' had
gone in transitioning that had largely
decreased pretty much entirely and this
is and this is what's interesting
because I know when we talk about a lot
of this stuff um every transsexual that
I know that trans that you know we
started feeling dysphoria around the
very time that we became self-aware
around the age of four years old um but
yeah I mean I knew around the age of
four that there was something different
and I wanted to be the opposite sex I
knew I wasn't the opposite sex but it
was something that I wished you know I
could I knew that there was something
different um and you know I try to dress
on at four years old and went from there
and then transitioned later in life when
um you know I finally accepted it myself
I'd be curious to hear your perspective
as someone I think you mentioned that
you have kids that have transitioned yes
I have that magical uterus my 11 my
third child came out at 11 and told us
that he was a boy he was assigned female
at Birth and so he socially transitioned
obviously cuz he was only 11 uh he is
now an 18-year-old College University
student and thriving um and then my uh
youngest child came out as a trans girl
at the age of 15 so um I live this with
my children um I made the TRU to the
emergency room with suicide um a suicide
attempt and a suicide plan with each of
my children did at any point did your
opinion on this is a gender dysphoria or
or a mental illness change as you know
you've had actual kids has transitioned
my opinion hasn't changed it's a mental
health condition but anti-depressants
weren't working we before uh Mitchell
came out we tried everything we'd been
to every single therapist and nothing
was touching it until we used he him
pronouns and that was all it took to
make things better for him initially and
then we did the medical
transition you know I don't even know
where to start here it's like sex again
sex is not assigned at Birth it's
established at conception we have to get
to biology here and the second thing is
we're seeing like this move I mean you
were mentioning the academic setting
notice how the the academic terms are
changing but this is a result of
pressure this is a result of societal
pressure that's what happened with
homosexuality by the way homosexuality
was recognized as unhealthy behaviors
now whether you call it a mental illness
or a deviant Behavior or destructive
Behavior that's a that's a point of
debate it's an unhealthy behavior for
sure and certainly it's the case with
transgenderism somebody cutting off
healthy body parts we have seen numerous
D transitioners now coming forward they
had severe health and mental problems
like the ones that you've talked about
but we sign we find that psych I have a
friend Kevin Kevin wit he's an outspoken
activist he's been on been on
commercials to protect children from sex
mutilation he was abused as a kid he was
he was beaten by his dad he was molested
by older kids when he was in school he
struggled with identity issues these are
horrific traumas that he endured and not
once did a counselor ever address those
deeper issues that's what needs to be
happening now let's actually hear from
the undecided
group so undecided Group which side do
you resonate with
more so why did you choose the liberal
side I do think it's a mental health
condition I I don't like calling it an
illness everyone has things they don't
like about their bodies I don't think
we're calling everyone mentally ill it's
interesting how you brought up con
conception and saying that gender is
soci conception because sex is a term
that's what I said not gender I said sex
sex sorry sex is AED conception because
established established okay it's
someone very close to me is trans and so
hearing it from people who identify as
trans themselves you can talk about
statistics and facts all day but if you
actually listen to people and what
they're going through and their
experience I feel like it's just
deeper you were on the undecided in the
previous prompt but now it seems like
you went on the conservative side what
changed and what arguments spoke to you
most to my knowledge the American
Psychological Association still
categorizes gender dysphoria as a mental
illness so just to stay on the side of
facts um and at this time what the
experts are categorizing as I'm going to
obviously side with that side I feel
like science has always changing its
definitions right absolutely uh we used
to drill heads and sides to fix
migraines um cu if that will change your
mind if that classification was taken
away well to my knowledge I think the
American Psychological Association
doesn't tend to uh later categorize it
under neurod Divergence rather than
mental like Illness but it's also
something that needs to be treated when
people with gender dysphoria go into um
get the diagnosis they do have to go to
a psychologist and get um a prescription
and this sort of stuff so it's part of
the process so just I understand that
science is constantly an evolving field
of study but as to what we know now I
think I'd rather just stay safe and stay
with the what the back say do you feel
like if they are to medically
transitioned that they need to go
through a series or rounds of different
psychiatrics tests well in the in um in
the case of children I think that would
be necessary just because this is I know
in some cases it can be reversible but
this is a life-changing decision so you
brought up the word lifechanging right
I'm curious if there's any question that
you'd like to ask either side because
that seems to be the big stipulation in
this kind of debate here um well I guess
I would like to ask the liberals did you
see in your own lives like vast
improvements like what did that look
like the vast improvements that you saw
uh my mental health was just largely
improved I was having a much easier time
I guess making friends cuz I was more
confident in my own identity my
children's lives changed completely it
was like turning on a light switch they
brightened they were more social they
excelled in school again after failing
um they just completely transformed
their lives yeah that's very interesting
you were on the conservative side and
now you're back on the undecided you
guys flip-flopped here what's something
that kind of brought you back into the
middle here yeah I would say I guess my
main reason for being here is that I
just am unclear as to like I guess the
difference between something being a
mental illness or mental condition I
know some people in the conversation
said that they use them interchangeably
some people said that they prefer to use
the term mental condition rather than
illness um you know I guess what kind of
differentiates those things if anything
I think you just hit the nail on the
head there changing the name of
something doesn't doesn't change the
fundamental reality that it there's a
there's a problem there's a mental
health issue that the person has it's a
disorder it's a it's a break from
reality that's just a fact the person is
born male or female and thinks that they
should be something else now regardless
of how that one treats that the fact is
and I I would submit even from the the
comments from the liberal side they
recognize that it's an illness that
needs to be treated I recognize that it
needs treating but it's not a break from
reality that's a
psychosis
py a psychosis is a break from reality
is a mental illness gender dysphoria is
not a psychosis but it is a break from
reality because the person thinks they
should be something else I think it's
pretty clear it's a disconnect between
reality you you're born male you're born
female but then your brain is saying
something else the cool thing about this
entire debate is that liberals for once
agree that there's possibly a soul right
they say you know I was born male or
female but something deep down something
in me is I'm actually this I'm actually
this reality is what is physical and so
if you are physically or biologically
male or female you don't need to change
your body you need to change what you're
thinking okay let's go back to the
undecided yeah did that help clarify or
is there any additional questions that
bring up um I guess it kind of did you
know when I think of like a mental
illness it is something that like we
treat and so I guess in that regard I
would I don't know if it's necessarily a
position I mean I feel like you know we
do talk about you know people who are
diagnosed with G dys like you treat that
with some I think in many cases I don't
know if it's all the time I'm sure it's
not all the time but in the majority of
cases you treat that with some kind of
transition whether it's a medical or a
social or both and so I mean I see kind
of that definition I feel like I mean my
takeaway is that I feel like they both
kind of agree with that and I don't know
necessarily that I think it's a
politically charged definition I think
it's like obviously how you interpret it
and like what is treatment what is
proper treatment you know what is
included within a mental illness what
isn't but I guess my takeaway I think is
like I think we or at least the
conversation the people in the
conversation I think they agree a lot
more on kind of the general topic it's
itself then maybe they might realize um
but of course when you get to
nitty-gritty I think there's that's
where you get the division the medical
community is pushing gender transitions
for financial gain so I disagree um I
mean when I was started started going
through my process of transitioning I
didn't feel pushed by any medical
professional at all there were in fact
quite the opposite a lot of hurdles and
just like bureaucratic red tape sections
I had to like work through but it's it's
not something that I think in my
experience was pushed on to me at least
yeah I completely agree with that when I
started my transition it took over a
year just for me to get to my third
doctor's appointment for us to actually
like talk and evaluate things and as far
as cost goes my insurance covered
everything but they're they are still
getting paid just the government or
somebody else is paying them I mean in
comparison to a BBL like Yeah well yeah
so so here but yeah but they're still
getting paid and they're still getting
Financial I actually think there's three
different types of doctors I think that
there are people that are going out
there and doing it for financial gain we
saw it in Vanderbilt we saw it in so
many other in instances where they are
doing it we also see that they are
manipulating the system that's why we
have a lot of d transitioners right now
and and that's why we're seeing that
that that Community grow is because
they're manipulating patients they're
manipulating parents and so this the
other the third is I don't know if it's
ineptitude or if it's um incompetence or
laziness but I think that there is a
section there's a there's a group of
mental health providers who simply right
now we want to cure everything they pill
and so we see this not only in the trans
Community but we see this in the SSRI
Community we see this everybody's being
put onto something and we're not really
treating the root causes it's one of the
reasons why we're seeing a high
comorbidity of like autism in the
community a lot of people that have
autism are getting sucked into this and
they're not being treated for the autism
they're treated for gender dysphoria so
one thing to uh consider and I did
research on this is that apparently
based of on top or bottom surgeries it
can actually range from around 10 to
25,000
from male to female transitions to
female to male Transitions and I think
you know what both sides can probably
agree on is that America is a for-profit
healthcare industry right we don't have
universal healthcare yeah anything to
consider there so so with the socialized
medicine with with the Vanderbilt
situation she actually said because of
Obamacare they have to pay for it and so
they they are forcing insurance
companies to pay for it so it became a
big money maker was her specific phrase
that she said I just want to remind
everyone that there are international
standards of care and there are many
countries out there that have social
medicine and it's not all for profit
Argentina and Denmark apparently are one
of the two countries that has included I
believe transitioning for minors in
their private and public health care
plans I I'd like to comment but I want
to give you a chance first um no it's
kind of hard to draw intentions
completely um with these kinds of things
I I completely agree with you that
America is a for-profit uh country and
so regardless of what trend or what
surgery is getting popular they're going
to find a way to make money out of it
yeah America is a for-profit and
everything but an EpiPen costs a whole
lot more than testosterone does so even
with that and we're once again the push
for being Trans in medical societies as
far as our experience go goes doesn't
really exist because two people here are
saying that you know it was quite the
opposite it took significantly longer
for anything to happen significantly
longer to try to do anything
significantly longer than you know as
far as like cosmetic surgeries or
anything like that go so I need to I
need I need to point out big Pharma
makes big money off of butchering little
boys and girls there is big money to be
made in this follow the money Ted hudo
he's a father who's been fighting very
hard because he's in a fraught divorce
his son was being put through the
transitions he saw in his medical bills
$200,000 for the chemical treatments
alone we could talk about the Jeff
younger situation Jeff is trying to
fight to save his son now his ex-wife is
taken the son here to transition him to
try to become a girl not only are the
medical costs being put upon him but
also legal costs so to your point though
so what we saw out of The Whistleblower
out of St St Louis who is a
self-identified queer woman who's
married to a trans man and she blew the
whistle on what's going on there now
where I hear a lot of adults um in this
situation say that it was a long process
for you um that's not what we're hearing
from d transitioners and a lot of these
patients and that's not what the St
Louis whistleblower said she said they
were basically pencil whipping um uh
psych psychologist letters so that they
could start Myers on transition and
that's one of the reasons why I think
that that clinic is also closing I mean
once again for me it's I'm always going
to go on personal experience before I go
on stats CU there are too many parents
people specifically who don't get
accounted into those stat statistics so
it's hard for me to be like yes this
number and yes this number I'm you know
whatever but for me it's like it took a
year and a half of therapy for me my
therapist who was also trans to go
through that process and write that out
for me to be comfortable or me to be you
know whatever it may be to get what I
needed so on top of that the money
situation there's so many trans people
who can't afford to transition whether
they're on insurance or not so for me
other people are paying for it what
other government Medicare Medicaid my
goodness this was a stop it here and
we'll askd group okay on the side of
group let's hear about which side that
you resonate with more liberals or
conservative you started off in
undecided then conservative and now the
liberal you've been all across the
Spectrum all over the place let's hear
about what kind of resonated with you
more to switch sides this time I'm sure
and confident that there are
practitioners out there who are pushing
people to transition who are just
signing off on prescriptions because yes
I mean you know like the points were
made that there is money to be made of
course but I don't know that I'd go as
far as to say you know that there is
this like I think someone mentioned on
the liberal side that there's like a
conspiracy going on I don't think that's
the case I think again there are
absolutely predatory you know
practitioners and maybe even a large
organization who are looking to profit
off of you know the medical
transitioning process um but you know I
think someone mentioned the aspect of
personal experiences and how for many
trans people it's extremely expensive
and even if you are on some kind of
insurance or even if you are on some
kind of plan it can still you know the
cost can you know Mount up a lot yeah
that's interesting too because I guess
in any movement right there going to be
people that take advantage about it for
their own selfish gains how much money
is I guess there to be made in the
transition that's a that's a hard
question to answer right because you're
creating medical patient for life so
it's over the course of a person's
lifetime that they would be buying
hormones and all this it's not accurate
you have to take trans person let's let
her speak let's let her speak let's let
her speak so so so you're right I mean
there are a lot of people that may come
off it's not it's more so on the trans
man's side than the transwoman side
where you have to be on hormones forever
otherwise it comes back and if you have
your SE if you have your primary sex
organs removed as well um so that's
that's kind of a hard question to answer
what it is over the course of a lifetime
I think they've estimated up to 100,000
to 200,000 but like one surgery so like
a vaginal plasty cost about 30 to 20 20
to $30,000 um I think the um the Val
plasty cost more um and then you get go
down a little bit with top surgeries and
stuff like that but it's still a
thousands of dollars you know at least I
mean a breast augmentation is about
$10,000 I've had children have surgeries
and medic medication for various
illnesses and I always find the way to
pay for it and I found the way to pay
for what needed in this
case how much did it cost what was the
General range I'm not comfortable
sharing that okay um I can say that for
me I I pay about like $10 every like
four months for my
medication and yeah that's pretty much
it so you've been kind of consistent
throughout in each of these prompts of
staying on the liberal side yeah is
there anything that you might want to
ask that may potentially maybe even sway
you to the other side or just something
maybe that you're not considering my
cousin is trans and he is so important
to me and so saying that it's it's a
mental illness saying that it's pushing
when you can see that so many trans
people of color are being denied
treatment I just I don't think that
that's fair to say that it's pushing I
just I feel like it would it would I
would be disrespecting someone very
close to me if I was over there and
saying that it's mental illness and then
they're pushing transitioning just so
they can make money okay so you're back
on the undecided what what made you stay
here it's a bit dangerous to generalize
or demonize the medical community and
state that there's like a wide
contingent or conspiracy trying to push
um transitioning especially if we don't
have evidence of it I think there's
probably like um he was saying evidence
of predatory practitioners and that sort
of thing if it brings them sort some
sort of financial benefit we do have to
question whether their motives are
entirely pure but that could be true of
like any disease so it's it's kind of
both sides I think had good points and
both um were kind of right so I'm I'm
not in the middle cuz I can't make a
decision I'm more in the middle because
I agree with them both schools should
include trans conversation in sex aded
an age appropriate time I agree yes what
is that age appropriate I think by
grades three or four they understand so
like around 8 n or I don't know anymore
my kids are too old but that sounds
about right I think eight or nine years
old is a good time because gender is a
concept that is formed in the mind of a
child around the ages of two three or
four years old by the time they're seven
or eight they understand the permanency
of gender so I think that's a good time
to introduce it now should they be
talked about as just as much as let's
say heterosexual sex or more in in terms
of including different historical
relevancy anything like that I think it
would be great to introduce the
difference between gender expression
gender identity and sexual orientation
because that is three completely
different Realms and children can
understand the difference between gender
expression and gender identity at that
age without ever having to talk about
sex yeah I definitely disagree um I
think especially what they're proposing
right now a lot of the mainstream sort
of education on sexet is pretty like
vulgar you're looking at a couple like
books you see a lot of parents going out
to like City committee meetings and
they're reading books in front of like
the school committee and the schol has
to like stop the the the entire thing
because they're reading such vulgar
stuff if I had to push back on that
though kind of we've been going through
like different personal experiences and
some of these cases we might just be
hearing about because they're the most
extremist of cases do you think that's
what's going on or do you think it's
more of a common prevalent uh instance
that's happening around the country um I
mean yeah I mean there's there's a
differentiation between personal
experiences and just what's going on in
general and so of course you're going to
see like the more popular cases on
social media and stuff but what it
really blows down to the question isn't
really so much what's the content but is
it true and it's not true and so why
should kids be learning about it I mean
personally I think that sex education
should be simple biology and then
anything above that should be an opt-in
system to where parents have to opt
their children into that into those into
that learning and I really don't think
it's the responsibility of teachers to
be talking to Children about that I
think it really boils down to it is a
parental rights issue and parents make
the ultimate decision how their children
learn that um I I disagree only because
like where I'm from North Carolina and
there was a point where sex as wasn't
being taught and then there was a point
where it was and when they started
teaching sex ed there were children that
were coming forward about like being
touched and appropriate and things like
that because they didn't know that those
things were inappropriate Parts because
they hadn't been taught otherwise so not
teaching children about their bodies
about their sex about their gender about
their expression you're eliminating them
you're you're giving people pedophiles
specifically the opportunity to pray on
them because they don't know any better
you're leaving them in the dark as far
as like gender is concerned like being
trans had I learned about what trans was
at an early age I think I had a would
have had a very a much happier life in
general by 21 I was going into
transitioning everything like that but I
felt and knew that there was something
specifically different by the age of
like six six seven without even knowing
what trans was and had I been taught
that transitioning later on in life
would have been completely different
yeah and like I said I think it was the
very first prompt we had I think almost
every transexual I know had that early
experience right that's Happy in their
transition so I I agree I just I I
really think it is the parentals it it's
parents responsibility the schools are
supposed to pick up where the parents
fall off that's a whole point of sending
your children to school no your parents
have the right to make the decision for
you okay I I just want to interject
right there and that is a very us way of
thinking is that par parental rights
Trump everything else because there's a
Convention of children's rights
worldwide and the US is the only country
who hasn't signed on to it so children
in other countries have rights before
their parents do and I think that it
should be taught in schools to protect
the child not just so that the parent
gets to make all the rules yeah okay
let's go to the other side of group
which side do you guys resonate with
more liberals or
conservatives I think we have all
undecided here uh let's start with you
um because this is interesting because
you've always been on the liberal side
until now what spoke to you that made
you undecided in this instance well I
would just like to mention that I
actually work in childcare and I work
with children and so um as much as I
think that we should have comprehensive
um sex education I think that 5 years
old is a bit young um I think maybe
Middle School age like 10 to high school
I don't think that um parents should
have completely all to say because if
that parent is
um more on one side or the other then
they are going to push their child to do
what they want them to do and their
child should be able to make that
decision for themsel once they are at
that age maybe both sides actually do
accept you know the fact that trans
individuals exist however more of the
discrepancy is around the age and what
when it's being introduced what do you
think yes I I think she mentioned around
eight or nine I think that's a good age
I have a little brother who's 11 and
when he was around that age he was able
to understand that I was queer and that
my cousin was trans and he was able to
understand that we were we were
different uh I would say around eight or
nine is is probably fine in my opinion
because that's generally the age in
which children have a solid grasp on
their own identity and um it's usually
you know about 10 years after that maybe
that they on average will disclose that
but at that age is when kids will
usually figure out that they're not sis
if that's the case um this lady she Ted
they started out with this concept of
permanency I just thought that was so
profound undering the point that I've
been making from the outset that sex if
you want to call it gender is there's a
permanency about it that needs to be
respected and when you're teaching
little kids about transgenderism you're
automatically injecting confusion that
feeds to the very contagion that we were
talking about at the outset it breeds
this confusion into children um that's a
real problem I agree with the point that
was made here um I don't think that sex
should really be pushed on to kids at
all I mean for hundreds of years public
education didn't teach sex said and
things went pretty well you didn't have
all this confusion and regarding the
situation about pedophilia or otherwise
you don't need to teach a children about
children about transgenderism for them
to know that somebody shouldn't be
touching your private parts did that
help clarify your points um you know I
did I think you know my takeaway I guess
you know I would say I still kind of am
unsure where I would stand specifically
like in terms of age ranges and you know
content but I think you know for me I
think there is kind of for me at the
center of it is that conflict between
you know parents that don't want
specific things to be talked about and
then parents who just don't care at all
but at least knowing that the
conversation's going on and maybe
signing off on that I know we've seen
that in the past with you know like
taking the slips home and being you know
showing the parent if they you know like
we're going to take the kids into
classes day we're going to talk about
this you know sign off if you want them
to or not however wouldn't that kind of
intr a bit introduce a bit of a slippery
slope what if that happens when it comes
to discussions around history around
race do you think that could lead to
parents kind of essentially shaping the
worldview that may not be factually
accurate you know when you start talking
about I guess you know teaching about
like sex head and let's say gender
expression sexual orientation I think
you do walk a different line between
like you know bringing up points of
history or you know even like the
Sciences I mean everything you know what
you include in a curriculum whether it's
science factual even mathematics like
there's some kind of you know political
basis there whether it's super political
or super apolitical I mean there's
always going to be interests there and
so I think what's really important is
you know curriculum transparency with
parents I think parents and students
should be involved in the development of
that process so that everyone at least
has a say or at least can see what's
being talked about at the table you
really have bounced around everywhere so
I'm curious if you wanted to ask like
any specific things part of my issue I
think with the idea of like having it
mandatory at certain ages um is that
some kids and this is why I do think
parents should have the right to pull
their kids out because I think some
parents are like the really involved
parents do know what their kids are
ready for and what they aren't some kids
are not quite ready for those
conversations I think one thing that I
heard that was a little concerning to me
on the liberal side and kind of kept me
here was I did hear someone I think say
something about a parents of other
cultures not being willing to and I I
I've lived in five countries I've lived
in two Muslim majority countries I've
lived in a Hindu technically should be
secular but Hindu majority country and
I've lived in a Catholic country and I
think the Western mindset and how we
approach issues and we have to
understand like when you're coming out
of the country and you're bringing your
children into a new culture as an
immigrant you want to keep your values
at home right and there's things that
you're going to be concerned about and
nervous about partially because of like
religious affiliation maybe or just not
experiencing it and so if schools want
those conversations to happen the focus
needs to not be going directly to the
children but it needs to be going to the
parents it needs to be prioritizing
assimilating the parents and the culture
so they are aware how to have the
conversations with their kids at home
because what ultimately happens is If
the child is learning something at
school and they feel like they can't go
home to their parents and the parents
find out about it in a way that's not
you know congruent or whatever this
creates a like a distrust from those
parents with the school system and you
know I mean that that just brings chaos
to America that's that's very serious
issue do you think this is a uniquely
American problem I think it's a western
Viewpoint problem miners are capable of
making life-altering decisions yeah
absolutely disagree there's no way uh
minors aren't able to make decisions
whether to join the military uh get
married or make tattoos and so when we
talk about something that's super
important like uh sex gender whatever
you want to call it um there's no reason
we should be chopping up kids putting a
bunch of hormones in them that are super
dangerous that we don't want we don't
quite know the effects of and then
completely change in the life that's
what I'm like really passionate about
especially just I think this this is
like the voice just this is the
sentiment among like a lot of Americans
is you can do what you want but why mess
with the kids and so that's where kind
of I'm at it's like why mess with the
kids for the purpose of this discussion
we're defining minors as under 18 when
you say that we don't know the effects
of these chemicals and these drugs and
all that it's worth mentioning that
generally speaking all these medicines
that are used were first introduced to
be used to treat CIS people for various
things um Joe Rogan for example takes
trt very similar drug to what transmen
take um estrad dool is used to treat
menopause sometimes there are people who
take spironolactone which is some taken
by trans fems people take that same drug
to treat blood pressure yeah but when
we're talking about minors specifically
um it's an issue because I don't I don't
think that they have the cognitive
ability to consent to long-term
decisions especially when we start to
see like we talked about we can talk
about studies like studies show that 90%
will end up desisting by the age of 20
we know what puberty blocker like
puberty blockers for example what they
do for precocious puberty but they've
never been studied and they're not FDA
proved they're prescribed off label for
for people in key ad growth years and
Adolescence and so we're starting to see
even Mary Bowers talked about starting
somebody on puberty blockers and then
going straight to cross seex hormones
and every time they're never able to
fully you know achieve orgasm as an
adult every single person that she's
ever had and she's the president of w
paath you have to do the studies you
have to figure out and you have to put a
pause button on it otherwise what we're
doing is literally experimenting on
children so one thing that's also
important to consider too is that
currently there are laws right when it
comes to voting uh you know drinking
alcohol even buying cigarettes at this
point right I think that is something to
consider in terms of this debate we
don't hold someone's hand when we go in
to vote we go in and vote on our own
when a child who is 16 makes a medical
decision to transition it is made with a
team there's parents there's
psychologists there's endocrinologists
it's not just one child walking in all
by themselves to do it by themselves We
Trust children to prepare our food for
us at fast food restaurants We Trust
children to drive combines on Farmland
in all 50 states why can't we trust a
child to tell us that they are not
comfortable and that we need to treat
them medically with a medical transition
because those are practices those are
jobs that that aren't going to affect
their lives forever so that's not even I
mean you that comparison just isn't
going to work at all that's the first
thing getting back to the getting back
to this question children cannot commit
to these life-altering decisions they
don't even know what life they can have
there are so many options that are
available available to them and they get
cut short you're making statements about
how they have all these adults guiding
them into this that's the whole point
they're guiding them into getting their
bodies mutilated when they should be
dealing with the mental health issues
Wallace Wong is an unscrupulous Medical
Professional in British Columbia and he
is part of the whole profit regime they
are rushing kids into these procedures I
know this because a father found out
that his daughter was being transitioned
with as knowledge or without knowledge
or permission and when he was telling
the public about it he went to jail
that's what Canada does so it's not just
about big Pharma making big money it's
about taking advantage of children that
have serious problems I'm making a
personal story here I hope you're
listening okay this is like this is
horrendous stuff these children are
confused they have mental health issues
and they shouldn't be stigmatized I want
to be very clear about that but the
answer isn't to put them under the knife
or put chemicals into them that will
alter them permanently I don't
necessarily believe that body's pushing
anybody to be trans like when you're
like leave the kids alone it's like look
at how you talk about trans people who
would want to be Trans in that sense
like who would want to be pushing
somebody into that lifestyle to be
Happ talk I'm I'm passionate about it
I'm sorry how many friends I've had who
have been mutilated just because you
might not have been able to make that at
that age does it mean everybody that's
16 or 17 can't make that choice at that
age there's so many 16 and 17 year olds
who have been emancipated who have been
you know not emancipated but when they
take care ofs elves legally and like
their own their own legal guardian at
that age they're making that specific
decision that I'm old enough and mature
enough to make this decision for myself
and my life like just because you
couldn't do it doesn't mean somebody
else can't yeah I I just I to disagree
it's just the laws disagree with that
right so we have laws against again
against marriage joining the military um
alcohol drugs all these sorts of
different things but that has nothing to
do with them as people yeah but overall
um yeah there are laws against these
things and so we're talking about people
we're talking about a group of people
who believe in Santa right you're seeing
you're seeing younger and younger people
get uh transitioned right you're talking
about people with there tenuous tenuous
grip on reality there's no reason we
should be pushing sex when I was 13 14 I
was thinking about uh my friends video
games Sports Let's uh go to the
undecided which side do you guys
resonate with
most
so I actually want to pick up right
where we left off how old are you 17
have you gone through different phases
throughout your life when I was three
and four I really wanted to be famous I
wanted to be a movie star I wanted to be
a
singer um when I was 6 to 7 I wanted to
rule the world actually quite literally
um I thought I I thought I'd do a great
job I thought I knew everything um one
thing I really wanted to do and I was
really into this idea was building
islands and taking all my friends and
family there and like we could have our
own little Community type of thing um
and then when I was basically like 12 I
think 13 maybe basically up to 15 I was
really into the idea of becoming an
endocrinologist because of s the awesome
endocrinologist I had and then when I
was 16 so this would have been last year
um kind of realized after failing
chemistry that maybe medicine was not
for me so um I took a government class
that I loved and I've always had a love
of politics and that sort of stuff so
now I'm kind of focused on getting into
international relations and politics
well I mean at least you're doing the
famous part well right now um so you
went through different you know four to
five different stages but you're kind of
like on the liberal side at the moment
can you explain why you decide to step
on this stage there are certain age
groups that probably should not be
making life-altering decisions like 3 to
four year- olds absolutely not but it
does ultimately I do think parents do
need to be involved with that just
because parents do often times have
their best children their children's
best interest at heart even if at times
to the public or to the child it seems
unfair so I agree but maybe just a
little less with the conservative side
this time people also have said that you
don't even develop your prefrontal
cortex until you're 25 you know I'm 26
and I feel like I can probably resonate
with that I think the conservative side
kept bringing up how there's certain
things that you can't do like in certain
age groups I think they're talking about
like um joining the military uh drinking
but in Europe you can drink at 16 um in
the US you can drive at 16 but in other
countries middle Eastern and European
you can't drive till 18 so how do we
determine like in actuality what the
limits are do you guys have any thoughts
amongst you you two of what made you
guys go to the conservative side I'd
love to hear a discussion between you
two the one thing that really resonated
with me is is we're talking I think he
said we're talking about kids who people
who still believe in make beliefs I just
don't think they understand the gravity
of the situation maybe not just
transitioning but there's certain
decisions that they don't understand the
gravity of I would push back a little I
think like especially when it comes to
teenagers I would say like 15 16 I would
say high school Range I think like we
should probably give them a little bit
more credit I think you know when it
comes to something like that I mean I
would say like I think it's of course
you know I mean we're talking about
Minor it's a huge range but I think we
should in general give a little bit more
credit where it's due to them I will say
the reason I'm here is because I think I
just agree fundamentally with the idea
like making life altering choices I
don't think you know anyone under the
age of 18 I guess maybe might be
arbitrary but you know in that minor
range as we've defined it in this
country I would agree I don't think you
know life altering whether that's a
medical transition or even something
like you know like what school you go to
like what college I mean you know minors
make decisions like that all the time
but they're not most of the time and I
would hope usually they're not you know
completely on their own you know we have
support systems and I think what's
really important is that we extend those
support systems so like counseling and
you know people at schools and you know
educating parents so that students
aren't going into decisions completely
on their own minors should be allowed to
medically transition
absolutely not that has not changed for
me we're talking about mental health
issues and there are a whole host of
problems that children deal with when
they're struggling with Identity or
gender dysphoria let's treat those
issues let's treat those causes I have
mentioned numerous cases of former
former trans kids who were pushed into
it parents who tried to protect their
kids and were punished for doing so this
is a very fraught Affair this these are
irreversible damaging procedures and we
have so many D transitioners that are
coming out warning the the Next
Generation not to do this I think it's
worth mentioning that the D
transitioners while I do sympathize with
them and I think it's unfortunate that
the medical system has failed them there
are statistical anomaly in the grand
scheme of how many people have
transitioned medically and surgically
that's we don't know that though so the
issue is we don't know what the D
transition rate really is simply because
they're falling off the rules if you
don't have your primary sex organs
removed then you can literally stop
taking hormones and nobody's following
up on them also we also know that the uh
the longest study out is the fiveyear
study and the average D transition takes
place four to 10 years after and so
those people are not being counted in
those studies I think that we should be
working on Mental Health Coverage we
should be getting them to an age of age
of adulthood um we shouldn't be
mutilating them um as at a young age and
and and I think that they like he said
like your prefrontal CeX is where you
make impulse decision making and so
that's what develops last and so we
should be getting them there I think we
can look at Social transition social
transition might not be a zero sum game
because we see that it kind of generally
leads to transition but let them
socially transition get them to
adulthood and see where we're at I agree
let them socially transition use hormone
blockers start trying cross hormones at
an appropriate age when the body is
ready to be receiving cross hormones
later on I also agree that we shouldn't
be mutilating children I don't believe
anyone's being mutilated but surgery
doesn't have to happen before 18 if they
are already being treated with cross
hormones or hormone blockers and we can
wait until they're 18 if we are helping
them and affirming their gender I don't
believe anybody has an agenda of
chopping children up yeah I would just
say ultimately those who are promoting
this and those who are accepting it will
be accountable we're seeing a lot of
different lawsuits coming out uh there's
a transgender or the transitioner who is
now suing Kaiser Permanente up in um in
like San Jose area because she felt like
she um she he I don't even know what
gender they are but um they felt like
they were um led into this they were
they were tricked they were kind of ran
into that system and now they're suing
and you're going to see a lot of Rise of
these lawsuits and so just to finish I
would say that um children are too young
to transition they can't fully grasp
this concept and then also it's just not
true and so we shouldn't be pushing it
for kids and I think the solution to
this is accepting who you actually are
accepting your actual body going through
therapy and you know I'm a Christian
seeking the gospel letting let we're
made in God's image and likeness and so
Allowing God to speak into that through
prayer and sacraments and yes I get the
argument of you know you're not
developed until you're 25 but if that's
the case then people shouldn't be
experiencing anxiety until I'm at 26 if
that's going to be like the main point
of argument like you know I started
paying bills and working at 15 16 and
put myself through school I bought my
first car 16 te but my my second car my
third car all on my own and I wish
somebody at that time had looked at me
and told me that I wasn't allowed to be
making specific decisions for myself
because you know I think that's on a
personto person basis and I completely
agree with you that if they're at that
time they're ready for that then they're
ready for it and if they're not they're
not so now let's see the final decision
from the undecided
group now undecided what's your final
decision
[Music]
so what's been great about this video is
that a lot of you guys have switched
different spectrums so let's start out
with what made you go to the liberal
side um I think that you made some
really good points um about being able
to um start puberty blockers and
socially transition and like surgeries
do not need to happen before 18 they can
happen after but as long as
the person can decide to start Fury
blockers and decide to socially
transition because what if they don't
make it to 25 what if they're not still
alive to transition at 25 when they're
fully developed so like I just don't um
sorry and like I seen my cousin that I
mentioned um I
I just I can't imagine my life without
them and if they were not like if
they're not able to
transition um I know the effect that
will have on their life and I just I
can't imagine
it I think for me what made me come to
the conservative side is I definitely
think that social transitioning is
acceptable um I think of the case of
like Angel jelina Jolie's um daughter
who went through a long long phase of I
guess we not entirely sure if it was
gender D for or not but wanted to
present as male and then came to an age
when they did decide that that was
something they no longer wanted to do
and so I I really respect that opinion
and I am also concerned about that I
really genuinely we also if we're not
entirely sure like what the medical you
know transitioning has long-term effects
or like the medicine itself on brain
development and all that stuff I think
we should just be very wary of letting
children transition even if it is with
um medical you know teams cuz as you
said earlier science is constantly a
changing field I still lean very much
towards the but I think if I had to pick
I lean right now a little bit more on
the conservative side and I think I
think the point you made about how we
just don't know really like the D
transition rate transitioning is a
process you know medical transition also
social transition and you're absolutely
right you know in 10 years from now you
know someone's experience might not be
the exact same I'm not saying that
that's the case for everyone I'm saying
that that's probably still not even the
majority of people but I do think it's
still a significant amount to to take
into consideration there's still a lot
that maybe we just don't fully
understand and I think until we get to
that point I'll just air on the side of
caution at least that's how I see it
clearly we all have our own biases and
hopefully we can consider all these
different personal experiences as well
as statistics so thank you thank
you